[Música]
alena joven muchas gracias por aceptar
darnos este paseo a través del arte
latinoamericano en los museos
canadienses dígame por donde hay que
empezar como el primero como está muy
bien muchas gracias paloma por la
invitación es un enorme placer estar
aquí con usted esta mañana muchas
gracias salen entonces tenemos mucho
camino por recorrer porque usted en su
investigación se dio cuenta que el arte
latinoamericano de varias épocas de la
historia digamos del arte
latinoamericano está presente en casi
todo el país en muchísimas regiones de
canadá entonces tenemos un camino largo
o una trayectoria larga para para
descubrir este arte dígame por dónde
comenzaremos usted a dónde nos lleva en
principio bueno para el escoge algunas
obras un poco al azar pero también para
que sea representativo de las
colecciones canadiense y algunas son
historias de amor a primera vista este
textil es muy fino en los detalles cada
son animalitos con fibras de
de lana y lo importante de ese textil es
que está conservado casi completo en
perú en la zona es una zona muy seca que
ha permitido que ese textil se conserve
en muy buenas condiciones
el problema con los textiles que no se
pueden siempre enseñar en los museos
porque hay que controlar la luz hay que
controlar la humedad entonces cuando se
sacaba un textil no puede quedar en
exposición mucho tiempo y en ese sentido
realmente ese es una obra sumamente
preciosa tanto en su trabajo
y en su estado de conservación
[Música]
bueno eso en todas las cuestiones
arqueológicas no se sabe el autor
obviamente y el periodo sé que los
especialistas han determinado que desde
la entre 200 años antes de la era de
cristo y 300 años después de la era de
cristo entonces es un término muy
antiguo si es muy antiguo y estar como
usted dice perfectamente conservado es
increíble porque es un clima muy seco y
eso ha ayudado a la conservación
de la pieza claro qué interesante además
esta obra que entonces por lo que veo
sería de us de más o menos 2.300 años
lo cual es increíble exactamente si
bueno sigamos entonces en mentira la
lícita
raquel forner es una artista argentina
entonces cuando escogí las obras quería
balancear digo la obra anterior no
sabíamos el autor pero más avanzamos en
el tiempo los artistas firman sus obras
y yo obviamente quería balancear quería
una mujer
y por alguna razón esa obra
me habló el título que puso la artista
es mutantes a llenados entonces quién
sabe en qué estado mental estaba yo
vivía pero me gustó el colorido este la
expresividad de la obra y es una
litografía entonces vamos a ver que hay
mucho textil hay mucha cerámica porque
es representativo de las conexiones
canadienses pero en el museo de bellas
artes
nada hay también una colección muy
importante de obras en papel también el
papel es un objeto una materialidad muy
frágil entonces hay que protegerla
porque él sufre de la luz sufre de la
humedad
pero la colección es muy importante aquí
escoge una mujer argentina pero también
la hay grabados y litografías de
artistas mexicanos hay dibujos pero
bueno yo quería un poco este balancear
las cosas digamos entonces aquí en
montreal el mismo museo de bellas artes
así es esta obra es muy impactante por
el tamaño porque es que me llega yo creo
que hace mucho tiempo que no voy pero o
sea unos dos metros y medio 225 de alto
entonces más alto aquí yo es de un
colectivo artístico cubano que se llama
los carpinteros
y es un estuche así así se llama un
estuche y la traducción en inglés que le
pusieron de wii keys o sea que son los
cajoncitos se pueden abrir para poner
joyería pero si ve la forma de afuera no
es no parece de joyería verdad es de
guerra exactamente
entonces ese nos habla del poder del
arte que a veces objetos cotidianos se
pueden convertir en otras cosas esta
obra fue adquirida por el museo de
bellas artes hace un par de años creo
que fue en el 2007 o el 2008 cuando el
museo de bellas artes de montreal
organizó una exposición de arte cubana
entonces en ese momento se decidió
adquirir la obra y bueno para mí era
importante mencionar la presencia de
colecciones de arte cubano en canadá no
solo en el museo de bellas artes pero en
otras partes por todo lo que está
sucediendo ahora en cuba a raíz de los
artistas que están manifestando y
pidiendo este más derecho a hablar a
expresarse de manera libre yo creo que
en ese sentido esa obra es muy muy
poderosa clara porque hay que decir para
la gente que nos está escuchando que
tiene la forma de una granada de una
granada que se lanza y que explota y que
crea como sabemos
literalmente muchos daños pero que a lo
mejor de manera más metafórica quiere
crear un cambio claro sabemos
interpretarlo así ahora vamos al museo
de la civilización de la ciudad de
québec y seguimos en la ciencia de
quebec vamos para allá
allí consagramos esta obra que me parece
que es antigua
es bueno esta antigua pero no tan
antigua como la el textil que
distribución de bellas artes
esa fue para mi amor a primera vista
mis intereses personales van hacia el
arte colonial que originalmente a la
colección de lyon el agua y en el agua
fue un diplomático canadiense que estuvo
en méxico en la embajada canadiense en
la ciudad de mexico en los años 60 y
acumuló una colección de arte colonial
mexicano que eventualmente fue adquirida
por lo similar de quebec donde él había
estudiado y bueno con el tiempo ese
museo ahora es el museo de la economía
en la ciudad que ve que pertenece al
museo de la civilización
la colección yo en el agua es una
colección que está en bodega entonces
para mí es importante como rescatar esa
memoria
hay pintura como la que estamos viendo
religiosa sólo hay un retrato de un
joven desconocido todo lo demás las
demás pinturas son de temáticas
religiosas y también hay partes de lo
que eran los retablos de madera dorada
cornamenta van originalmente las
iglesias en el período barroco y la
peculiaridad de esta obra buena hay
varias cosas la la virgen que vemos
representado esta parada sobre una
columna se conoce como la virgen del
pilar que es una advocación española que
pasó a la nueva españa si se llamaba
méxico en el período colonial la nueva
españa como la nueva francia era que y
pues los españoles que venían a américa
traían también con ellos sus propias
devociones entonces probablemente un
español de nacimiento que viajó a la
nueva españa buscando fortuna era muy
devoto de la virgen del pilar y pidió
a un pintor novohispano de la nueva
españa nacido en el méxico colonial que
pintara esa representación si hay unas
pinturas de la colección leo en el robo
aunque realmente son fascinantes y es
una bueno para mí que soy colonialista
es una tristeza que no se dé a conocer
más esta colección ahora a ontario me
parece que me va mal eso sí
ahora les voy a hablar con tal vez un
poco más en general el museo gardner en
toronto es un museo totalmente dedicado
a la cerámica desde diferentes
civilizaciones diferentes períodos
históricos
entonces seleccione diferentes
objetos que representan las diferentes
culturas de las américas antiguas y esta
colección fue donada por los fundadores
del museo gardner
los esposos gardener y realmente lo
interesante es que eso en el caso de las
américas antiguas son objetos
arqueológicos pero visto en un contexto
de obras de arte
entonces la que vemos aquí es es una
botella si vemos tiene dos
las dos partes que están como paradas
arriba es donde se vierte el líquido
dibujado con este diferentes aves del
mar estas de perú de la de la parte de
la costa sur
y los especialistas las han pesado
alrededor de 100 200 años de la era
cristiana y es un objeto bastante bueno
es un buen tamaño pero tampoco es ni muy
chiquito muy enorme de 16 x 12
centímetros si vamos a la siguiente
vamos esto en el mismo museo es el mismo
museo esta es una obra maya y es así es
para beber y no cualquier bebida sino
chocolate el chocolate siendo originario
este de las américas y era un alimento
muy bueno todos sabemos que el chocolate
es muy rico pero en la época
prehispánica era reservado
entonces no cualquiera podía beber
chocolate es así los especialistas dicen
que es del año entre 700 800 de la era
cristiana de la región del petén en
guatemala
y bueno si pueden ver hay dos personajes
claro que el bajo da la vuelta y hay un
todo un discurso narrativo pero lo que
la persona que está a la izquierda es
una señora que está ofreciendo
justamente una copa de chocolate a la
persona que está enfrente de ella que sé
que sería como él
el jefe del jefe exacto exactamente
arriba de los personajes hay unos
dibujitos
si son glifos entonces los que son
especialistas pueden decodificar los
pueden a veces leer los nombres del
emperador que está ahí representado o
los años entonces pueden ser esos vasos
como vasos conmemorativos para celebrar
eventos importantes entonces cuando tomó
el trono este y guerras importantes
cosas así interesante qué maravilla muy
bien en esta parte de la colección del
royal ontario museum que llamamos el ron
el ron tiene un es no es como tal un
museo de arte
es más bien como un museo de las
civilizaciones
y su sección de arte latinoamericano
está dividido entre cosas arqueológicas
lujosas etnográficas y textiles
pero en cada en cada sección hay objetos
interesantes de américa latina esta es
un es como un dije de jade y es una cosa
súper chiquitita ahí estamos realmente
hablando de micro arte porque tiene 7
centímetros de alto y el jade no es una
piedra tan fácil de trabajar entonces
cuando la vemos así realmente podemos
apreciar los detallados del trabajo
cuando no tenían todas las tecnologías y
las herramientas que podemos tener hoy
para tratarla
el material extranjero mereció muy
difícil exactamente con el ahora ex es
eso también es parte de la civilización
maya pero más
un poco más reciente reciente entre
comillas de los años 600 a 900 de la era
cristiana y si no me equivoco creo que
sería de la región de honduras
increíble así está precioso quién no
querría tener un dije de esos colegas la
clave
bueno de hecho en méxico y me imagino
que no en otras partes también a veces
venden reproducciones entonces los
originales se quedan en los museos y uno
éste puede comprar reproducciones bueno
tendremos que hacer eso claro además y
sería es mucho mejor hacer esto y que se
mantengan los originales donde deben
estar
exacto exacto ahora que ya estamos bien
instalados en el museo rom en el royal
ontario misión vamos a esta otra pieza
elena que cuéntame es como escena
también esto es un lienzo exactamente se
llama el lienzo de a ver si lo puedo
decir bien claro el ipec tlapiltepec es
un lienzo de algodón con medidas
impresionantes de casi 4 metros de largo
por 169 de ancho
ese lienzo es de la región de la mística
no sé de lo que es hoy
oaxaca es un un códice bueno es un
lienzo místico [ __ ] es una de las
civilizaciones que se desarrollaron ahí
y lo interesante de esos lienzos es como
la memoria como vimos hace poco con el
vaso maya de chocolate que los grifos
cuentan historias y sucesos históricos
este lienzo también cuenta costas pero
lo interesante es que es post colonial o
sea que utiliza una técnica y un
lenguaje pictórico que es típico de la
pre conquista pero después de la
conquista por los españoles entonces esa
obra de arte es muy frágil es un lienzo
no está expuesto en sala pero hay un
facsímil un facsímil es una copia casi
exacta que se hace de la obra
con la idea de conservar y preservar el
original se desempate el finalmente el
facsímil es como un tipo de papel
exactamente es ese es el tejido original
el que estamos viendo en pantalla es el
tejido original pero si en algún momento
quieren ir a hipopótamos en algún
momento ir a visitar los museos de nuevo
es en la sala lo que se expone no es el
original sino un un facsímil con esa
idea de preservar el original bonita
obra y ahora nos vamos entonces a si
todo está bien la siguiente también
debería de ser del ron exacto eso es
otro bajo ceremonial que invierten esa
la colección del ron
se llama un queiro
los queridos son típicos de la área de
los andes perú bolivia y ese es del
periodo colonial los que nos existen
desde los tiempos prehispánicos en
tiempos prehispánicos a veces se hacían
de metales
valiosos como el oro o la plata pero en
el período colonial se siguen haciendo
pero con madera y a veces con
aglutinantes que son propios del lugar
y con dibujos vegetales y curativos que
no se encuentran siempre en los
prehispánicos entonces hay un los
especialistas tienen maneras de
reconocer cuáles son los priísta nikos y
los coloniales pero nuevamente
encontramos estos objetos híbridos que
vienen de una tradición y que traspasa
en el tiempo y las culturas y la idea
del clero es que era un vaso ceremonial
existía en dos copias exacta entonces
hacemos un pacto usted y yo cada quien
tiene su vaso intercambiamos palabras
para celebrar el honor cada quien bebe y
cada quien conserva su copa para
acordarse del pacto que se ha hecho
entonces en realidad son son objetos que
son como testimonios de un acuerdo
finalmente hemos acabado un acuerdo
exactamente 5 lamentablemente sabemos
que existían en pares pero
hoy día el otro par desapareció se
perdió y los que existían de plata y de
oro muchas veces fueron quemados por el
valor del material imaginado fueron
fundidos para ser utilizados en algo más
de imagina en joyería probablemente para
algún rey si posiblemente si vamos ahora
a la mansión textil de canadá si en
toronto
hay un museo dedicado exclusivamente al
textil no sólo latinoamericanos sino de
todas las partes del mundo obviamente
hay textiles canadienses americanos y
asiáticos pero tienen una muy rica
selección de textiles
obviamente como le comentaba antes los
textiles son objetos muy frágiles
entonces no están siempre expuestos pero
en usted es muy activo en tener este
exposiciones temporales y toda su
colección es disponible línea entonces
uno puede ir a ver a consultar que
tienen este de obras de textil tienen
una muy fuerte colección de
huipiles guatemalteco también tienen
objetos textiles arqueológicos y tienen
cosas más contemporáneas que podrían ser
vistas como objetos etnográficos de arte
popular cosas así la que estamos viendo
este
es un textil que se pone en la cabeza es
de la región de chichicastenango en
guatemala y desde principios del siglo
20 entonces no es arqueológico pero es
bastante antiguo y lo que quería
comentar es bueno el textil guatemalteco
también es uno de mis favoritos porque
son dibujos muy animados en este caso
son como gallinitas entonces ese es un
trabajo manual pero muy fino muy difícil
no sé si se imagina cada uno de esos
detallitos hechos bueno tienen sus
telares lo imagino
se hacen con tela sin pelar de cinturas
que es una tradición una técnica que
todavía se aplica hoy día cuando
visitamos los pueblos en guatemala que
las mujeres están sentadas y tienen el
telar de cintura amarrado al tronco de
un árbol o sea todavía son medidas muy
tradicionales de trabajar el textil esta
también es del museo del textil de
toronto
es importante porque es un poncho de la
bueno que es de finales del siglo 19 y
es de chile de la región mapuche
entonces hoy día oímos hablar de los
mapuches en las noticias pero son muy
pocos ejemplos que se conocen de
textiles antiguos cuando no es
arqueológico pero es bastante antiguo
del siglo 19 y por eso para mí era una
obra importante de enseñar entonces esto
nos habla un poco de la variedad de
textiles que tenemos en canadá entiendo
las formas que no se usan de manera
cotidiana porque ese poncho no era
cualquier poncho era un poncho
ceremonial este que sólo se usaba en
algunos eventos muy importantes
entiendo y también en este caso se trata
de una donación como en el anterior
exactamente exactamente perfecto y es
hasta en otro museo en la galería de
arte de ontario sí que llamamos el río
ahorcado y octavio en toronto el litio
tiene una colección
muy interesante de obras
latinoamericanas son como tres puntos
muy fuertes una son obras brasileñas
pintura como la que estamos viendo aquí
de rubén valentín emblema número 15 de
los años 70 esa colección ahora no me
acuerdo cuántas fueron creo que fue como
20 cuadros que fueron donados por una
compañía que se llama rascan la mente
que era una compañía que tenía intereses
en brasil haya compraron obras y bueno
pasó por diferentes museos hubo una
exposición muy importante que se hizo en
los años 70
que recorrió varios museos canadienses
y finalmente la colección fue donada a
leyó y me metí en una compañía
canadiense brasileña o canadiense con
intereses en brasil de brascan brascan
exacto brasil canadá
a mí lo que se me hizo interesante es
que son cuadros como podemos ver que o
sea son
muy con colores muy llamativos ahora
seguimos el paseo y vimos que vamos
ahora a ver si no me calo vamos a ver
ahí es donde como historiadora del arte
juego con los términos del arte estamos
en el museo de antropología que está
asociado con la universidad de propios
colombia el museo de arte de
antropología no es un ser
artístico no es un museo de bellas artes
pero tienen objetos de cultura visual
que vienen de américa latina que para mí
son importantes para que un público
canadiense conozca los objetos creados
por las civilizaciones latinoamericanas
y bueno como es un museo de antropología
muchos de los objetos son arqueológicos
como el que estamos viendo ahora que sus
dedos de esade
es un plato ceremonial o sea no es un
plato en que cualquiera da comida a su
comida cotidiana sino que es un plato
ceremonial por lo precioso de la pintura
de la policromía que se aplicó a la
pieza y por esas cabezas que representan
diferentes monstruos deidades y cosas
así
lo que quise él
representar aquí ese objeto es de la
cultura nico ya que es originaria de
nicaragua para demostrar un poco la
variedad de los objetos que encontramos
en la en las conexiones a bueno
arqueológicas precisa mal y se aprecia
nada exacto este que también está en el
mismo museo es cierto exacto está en el
mismo museo en la sección más
etnográfica
y es una pintura de ecuador que viene de
una región que se llama antigua y
antigua se hace tradicionalmente todavía
la hasta la fecha este tipo de pinturas
que es muy
representa vidas en las secciones más
rurales de ecuador donde podemos ver la
iglesia la gente festejando los animales
importante de la agricultura diferentes
festejos procesiones los mercados
entonces es una pintura no me gusta el
término popular pero en el sentido que
no necesariamente es un pintor que ha
estudiado que ha ido a la academia sino
que es algo más espontáneo si lo podemos
decir así y que representa la vida
cotidiana de alguna manera está contando
una historia está contando la historia
de su vida de ese día probablemente veo
algo que es importante para él o para su
familia finalmente así es y normalmente
son celebraciones puede haber una boda o
lo mercado es la fiesta de un santo
entonces son escenas que son muy
atractivas y el uso de antropología de
la universidad de british columbia en
vancouver tiene una colección muy
importante de pinturas de tigua entonces
ahora que yo quería éste traerá cuenta
es ajos claro yo que soy periódico
periodista yo diría que es casi como un
periódico un diario
si esa región de esa zona de ese día en
particular podríamos decir es el diaria
no ya no sé qué día fue en que lo hizo
pero hay una narración de qué pasó esto
la orquesta y otras son son detalles muy
muy bonitos
alina quisimos este recorrido canadá es
muy grande y lo logramos no fuimos a
todo canadá pero vemos grandes ciudades
y lugares importantes del país hemos
recorrido con estas obras
latinoamericanas pero qué es lo que
ustedes
retiene personalmente de este viaje de
estos descubrimientos que hizo del arte
latinoamericano en canadá como como de
manera profesional pero también de
manera personal
bueno la primera conclusión es esto hay
un material muy abundante
lamentablemente salvo algunos casos
excepcionales no son colecciones que se
han estudiado bien eso está por hacer y
a la par de las conexiones están las
exposiciones porque mi pregunta inicial
era como cuando donde el público
canadiense ha estado viendo obras
latinoamericanas aquí en canadá yo donde
y cuando ha sido expuesta entonces una
parte de la historia son las colecciones
pero muchas de esas colecciones están en
bodegas hasta estudiar falta descubrir
las colecciones particulares
yo estoy convencida que hay muchos
particulares que tienen colecciones que
no se conocen en canadá y ahí sería un
mundo por explorar también las
colecciones consulares o sea o
diplomáticas o sea la embajada el cónsul
de perú de méxico han de tener obras que
no están a la vista que no se sabe que
existen pero es parte de la colección
que está en canadá y como hemos visto en
el caso de brascan hay colecciones
empresariales que no se conocen entonces
si logramos y en eso es como un proyecto
de vida si logramos hacer dialogar esas
colecciones vamos a poder tener una
mejor idea este de lo que hay de américa
latina en canadá bueno ha sido un gusto
ahora tenemos una hora conversando y
creo que podríamos hablar bastante
tiempo más un enorme gusto paloma de
verdad se está vengando
gracias a mucho gusto de verdad
igualmente
[Música]